let's give a warm Arizona welcome to
Republican Arizona Senate candidate
Blake master
thank you
all thank you you know what's funny I've
offered all these Democrats time on my
show not one Raphael Warnock uh Mandela
Barnes uh the guy in the hoodie from
Pennsylvania
the trust fund brat that never worked a
day in his life uh Democrats won't come
on my show why do you think that is I'm
offering them an hour a full hour uh
good to see you you as well thank you so
we have pretty yeah pretty much here in
Arizona have a senator it's just like
Chuck Schumer or just like Dianne
Feinstein so
does that represent the values of
Arizona because I think I know Arizona
well I've been down to the border from
the Rio Grande to San Diego in Tucson
I've been down here 15 times and it's
out of control it is out of control what
do you think does Mark Kelly represent
us no he does not and you know what the
the frustrating thing is he promised he
would right he promised that he was
going to be independent he promised two
years ago when he was campaigning that
he was going to be some kind of moderate
well that's campaign Kelly and then he
got to DC he completely surrendered his
voting card to Chuck Schumer and he is
just a rubber stamp for this failed
Biden agenda I don't even understand why
this guy wants to be a senator he has
zero independence of Mine by the way how
many agree with me you slaughtered him
in that debate
wow
you know it's interesting when we get to
this
this point in an election year usually
if you're even with the incumbent any
last minute breaking votes go towards
the Challenger that would be towards you
you're now in a statistical Dead Heat
with Mark Kelly
um now we have a Libertarian in this
race
I'm telling everybody in Arizona and to
all my libertarian friends don't take
offense well you probably will I don't
care you're wasting your vote it's a
half a vote for Mark Kelly everyone
agree with me and you've had to go up
against that challenge uh have you
spoken with him I have spoken with him
although you know I think we're going to
drive that libertarian vote uh down to
about one percent maybe even less
because people know freedom is on the
ballot right if you care about Freedom
if you don't want some left-wing
totalitarian dystopia you've got to vote
Republican up and down the ticket and
that means in the senate race you've got
to vote for me
when I look at what is at stake this
election I break it down the real simple
stuff the stuff I was asking this great
crowd and that is 41-year high of
inflation record high gas prices wide
open borders we set a record last year
of the illegal immigrants coming into
the country was set a new record already
this year and we still have two and a
half months in in the year left uh then
you deal with Law and Order Safety and
Security so people can pursue happiness
and then the last one is I think parents
are sick and tired of the indoctrination
of their children in school
and they want to go back to the basics
of we were talking to Curry about it
um do you am I missing something
there's so many problems that Democrats
have caused it's kind of hard to know
where to start right but but we in
Arizona we bear the brunt of these twin
crises that they caused the Border
crisis and this crazy economic inflation
crisis and to pick on inflation for
instance I'm tired of people talking
about this as if it's some Act of God as
it's some mystery where did inflation
come from well two years ago inflation
was one and a half percent you didn't
even have to worry about it it came from
the White House it came from Joe Biden's
bad 1.4 and policies that Mark Kelly
supports in lockstep right what are the
two things they did they surrendered our
energy Independence right they just we
were energy independent how nice was
that right they took gas from two
dollars to six dollars by declaring war
on fossil fuels Sean what do these
Geniuses think was going to happen when
you declare war on oil and gas in a
country that's powered by oil and gas
you think you might shoot the cost of
energy up to the Moon listen I'd live
paycheck to paycheck for many years in
my early adult life it's not fun I can
afford it now I I get paid more than I
just deserve I hope my boss doesn't
watch it
um
but honestly I I get I get ticked off
I'm angry when I fill up a gas tank and
it's twice you know it's 120 bucks it
used to be 60 bucks I'm like this is
annoying and it's it's it's killing the
poor the middle class people on fixed
incomes one thing that I like about the
two of you is you you have developed a
rapport already well I could tell you
will work in tandem you'll work at the
federal level you'll work at the state
level and you have a shared philosophy
that will serve the people of Arizona
that is rare my saying that the right
way right there in the last name Lake
and Blake it's too good right
well we need our federal delegation I
mean we've got issues that we need the
FED to help with I mean we really do
when it comes to water and things like
that so we're going to work well
together and with Debbie lesko who's
here and and Congressman Brandy Biggs
Burgess Owen is here Utah yeah so we we
need our federal delegation we need to
get as many Republicans in it as
possible so we can get something done
for Arizona back in D.C that if you have
that Dynamic I've watched it before it
really works out well for the people you
know people forget that run for office
they're supposed to be public servants
that's right they lose track of that
these people are our boss the people of
Arizona are our boss a great way to do
it I like your analogy about a job
interview yes and Katie Hobbs is running
from the interviewer Katie Hobbs refuses
to debate I think Mark Kelly wishes he
refused to debate what do you think I
think that's good
all right Harry and Blake will stay with
us so all of you here in Arizona you
know all to all the dangers of Biden's
hope and borders and that agenda and to
help deal with the crisis the state is
now placed shipping containers along the
border with Mexico to help deter illegal
immigrants from crossing the Biden
Administration and they're now mad these
shipping containers you know it's like
building your own little wall Governor
dusek has started this and put this up
anyway so they're now Biden and Company
are demanding the containers be removed
we sent our very own investigative
reporter and friend uh Sarah Carter Fox
News contributor uh to the border to the
shipping containers and Governor Ducey
is saying I'm not going to remove them
Sarah with the lady
right now the State of Arizona is
actually in a battle with the federal
government I mean Governor Ducey is
actually trying to sue the federal
government because their Federal
government's trying to force the State
of Arizona to actually take down the uh
train cars that they're using to
basically these cargo containers right
to basically create a border in the gaps
correct so that's see that's what it
makes a big difference that people
sometimes don't understand it so we have
the immigration problem obviously right
where anybody can come across claim
Asylum and then they're getting released
that's a big issue then you got the
gotaways which which this area leads the
entire country in godaways there's
nowhere else more than here in this part
of Arizona and then you got the
narcotics
so it's it's it's three stages of of a
war so if you just take those down then
obviously that's where people are going
to come across that's where they're
going to turn themselves in that's where
agents will be preoccupied and then when
they move themselves from that area
having to do processing transport many
times Hospital watches now the drug
smugglers take advantage of that Gap and
then that's where they come through so
they're still going to be bringing the
drugs in obviously right but now it's
easier to direct it in different areas
you got to make it harder for them all
right we continue with Republican Senate
candidate Blake Masters uh and
gubernatorial candidacari Lake joining
us now on the stage is the president of
the national border patrol Council our
friend Brandon Judd good to see you
again sir how are you
so we went over Katie hobb's record the
record of Mark Kelly he voted against
title 42 three times he voted against
hiring 18
000 border agents but he did vote for
the 87 000 IRS agents and he voted to
defund the border wall construction
three times in 2021 alone uh you're down
there every day I've interviewed you how
many times
more than I can remember I've been I've
been on Horseback helicopter all-terrain
vehicle out on boats I've Been
Everywhere from the Rio Grande to San
Diego I've been in the drug warehouses
I've never seen anything like it in my
life one of the few you've been one of
the few in the in the actual media that
goes down there to try to understand
exactly what's going on now I'm an old
tanker so I send my reporters I keep
going down there though I will but
Sarah's done a great job yes and now the
fentanyl crisis ninety percent of
fentanyl ninety percent of opioids cross
that southern border right into this
state in Texas correct it is and it's
it's not just staying in Arizona and
Texas and that's the problem it's going
throughout the entire United States when
we see this drug epidemic that's taking
place it's in Ames Iowa it's in Lincoln
Nebraska it's up in Maine um obviously
in Florida it's going throughout the
entire United and then we've got the
cartels running it then we got human
trafficking we have underage sex
trafficking you've seen it all correct
yeah Sean I live this nightmare every
single day and I've I would have never
dreamed that it could possibly get this
bad I would have never dreamed that we
would have Governors that wouldn't do
what's best for their citizens I would
have never dreamed that we would have a
president of the United States that
doesn't care enough about his own
citizens to actually secure the Border
and go after the criminal cartels this
is easy we were able to do it under
President Trump he recreated the will
it's not like he he he completely did
something new and we were able to secure
the border and with proper Governors
with proper Senators we can get right
back to the support that we need to do
what's necessary to secure the American
people let's talk about this this team
Hari as Governor Blake is Senator
um now we have seen it was amazing 50
what two volunteers went to Martha's
Vineyard they were off that Island they
couldn't get him off the island fast
enough yeah 24 hours gone sample a
little taste of what we deal with with
50 people who are here illegally illegal
aliens going to Martha's Vineyard and we
deal with hundreds of thousands who have
come across our border yeah
shipping them around the country I think
I've told you that before but I do think
it Illustrated what we're dealing with
and it showed that they immediately
wanted to deport the people yet they
don't want us taking control of our
border on our own but we will we're
going to with my border plan take
control of the Border you are not going
to take you don't care what Joe Biden
says you are going to do everything
within your power and we see listen I
I've talked to Greg Abbott a lot he has
tried every single thing within his
power it as Governor you don't have the
authority to say you're you're out of
here and send them back well what we're
going to do is go to the U.S
Constitution Article 1 Section 10 right
we have an invasion on our border within
the first hour of my uh my
Administration we're going to issue a
declaration of invasion
and people want it if people demand it
and we are going to take control of the
Border Article 1 Section 10 of the U.S
Constitution allows us to do that we
have an invasion our people are in
danger and there's no time for delay we
meet all three criteria and we're going
to take control of the Border away from
the cartels and Blake you will be able
on the federal level as an elected
Senator to support and help her efforts
Absolutely I'll do everything at the
federal level to help Kerry get that
done at the state level you know it's
going to be frustrating it's going to be
frustrating because here's why
2022 this is a save the country election
so is 2024. they go together we need the
White House back in January 2025 when
God willing we inaugurate a strong
Republican president again it gets easy
right we'll pass a great piece of border
security legislation the president will
sign it well we will pass that out of
the House and Senate when we take back
the house and the Senate but Biden's not
going to sign it right so here's my
pledge for 2023 and 2024. I will grind
Biden's agenda to a halt unless and
until we get mortar securities
it's got a
it's got to be great for you and all the
people you work with every day you put
your life on the line you're dealing
with dangerous cartels you think you're
dealing with human traffickers drug
traffickers dangerous work and uh then
to have the support and that's and
that's what we need we have to have the
support of Governor we have to have the
support of senators we also have to have
the support of the congressmen we've got
Andy Biggs we've got Burgess Owens we've
got Debbie lesko these individuals can
step up to the plate and immediately
impeach secretary Marcus and then Blake
and go for that and then Blake can vote
to convict and then of course Governor
Lake can then give the support that's
necessary so that we can go after the
criminal cartels if we can go after the
criminal cartels we can save the lives
of our children our grandchildren our
neighbors and our friends and that's
what Senator that's what governor Lake
can do for us
uh the hour goes by quick we only got
like six minutes left should be over I
know can you believe it let's do two
hours
all right you have to negotiate with
Laurie I might get mad at me uh listen
this race is critical wishing you the
best of luck thank you in the governor's
race best of luck in the Senatorial race
Arizona
everything may be in your hands it may
come down to you right here in the state
thank you for being here hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else